-How are you?
-I'm good.
Just wore a little headband
for you, darling.
-I love that you wore
your headband tonight.
-I'm gonna play tennis later,
so I just thought I...
-But, like, you're gonna play
tennis at night without lights.
-Oh, sure. Of course.
This is what this is for.
Yes.
It's my sweatband and light.
-It's perfect.
[ Laughter ]
It's perfect.
I know very few people
who could pull it off, and
you are in that small category.
-I'm one of those idiots?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Actually purchased this myself.
Yep.
-Oh, good!
-Yep.
-Well, I'm glad. You're owning
up to it and everything.
-Yep.
-Yeah.
I hope it wasn't at the store
that I was gonna buy mine at.
-Yeah, they only had one.
-Oh, no!
-You're gonna have to go to the
other store that carries these.
-So, I want to ask.
You were in Vancouver,
you did a TED Talk.
-Which is when I bought this!
But sorry.
[ Laughter ]
It was my gift
after the TED Talk at Gucci.
-So for those who don't know,
I mean, were you nervous?
And what is the -- what is the
undertaking of a TED Talk?
-I was terrified.
-Uh-huh.
-You write a talk.
They don't like
to call it a speech
because it's supposed
to be a relaxed,
sort of conversational
situation.
Little did I know that
you don't have a teleprompter.
-Okay, so you got it memorized.
-Yes, but I was like,
"No, I'm gonna hold cards."
-What's the time limit?
-They like you to be between
9 and like 12 minutes.
-Okay.
-I did 10.
-Nice.
Well, that's right in there.
-It is. Check!
[ Laughter ]
I remember, when rehearsed it,
it was about nine, so I was --
you know, in the moment,
it got a little longer.
-Good.
-I was happy with my material
but terrified.
Kept rehearsing it, and
I don't know, and it happened.
It was honestly
one of the scariest things
I've ever done in my life.
I felt like every smarty-pants,
smarty, smarty person
was, like, sitting there,
looking at me like --
[ Scoffs ]
-Yeah,
Yeah, you don't get the sense
that dummies
show up to TED Talks.
-No.
So I was terrified.
-Yeah. And what was --
What were --
Who were the other people you
met over the course of doing it?
-Okay, well, first of all,
when you go to TED,
you get invited
into their community,
their TED community,
so you get join the TED app,
which is like a TEDConnect app.
-Okay.
-And I think it was so you could
create a community there,
but I thought
it was a dating app.
-Okay, got you.
-I've never been on a dating app
but I was like, "Oh, look!
There's a bio and a picture!"
I was like "This guy's cute!
This guy's cute!"
So my friend
that was with me was like --
she was like, "Let me so
who's in your network,"
and I was like, "Okay."
She was like, "Um...
everyone in your network
is a black man with a beard."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "Is that true?
Oh, interesting."
So I was, like, wandering around
at TED, like, thinking,
"I bet you he's in my network,
he's in my network.
Bet you that's one of
my guys in my network.
And then -- okay.
So, then, I rehearsed,
and the day I was supposed
to do my talk,
like two hours before,
they told me
I was gonna open the conference,
like, be the first person,
and I was -- excuse my French --
but [bleep] bricks.
-Yeah.
-I was a little out of my body.
Whatever.
But I'm still seeing my --
-Lot of pressure
to be the opener.
-Muh -- Yeah. Uh...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So I was a little
out of my body,
and I decided
that maybe I would have
some of the people
in my network,
like, some of the other
black folks that were there,
do a "Wakanda forever"
if I got on stage.
-Yeah.
-Seems like a great idea.
-Right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So I thought --
I thought it would, like,
give me a little Wakanda juice.
Do you know what I mean?
-What is a network for
if not that.
-If not for that.
-Yeah.
-So I am walking around, like,
telling people, like,
"Listen, I'm first.
I'm a little nervous.
If I go up there
and 'Wakanda forever,'
don't leave me hanging."
They were like, "We got you."
I was like, "Great. You got me."
I'm walking out
to go get myself together,
and I see this bearded man,
and I'm like, "My husband."
[ Laughter ]
Clearly.
So I'm walking towards him,
I'm like, "Bearded, yeah, yeah."
And he's like, "Hey."
I'm like, "Hey."
And he's like,
"This is my wife."
I was like, "Not my husband."
[ Laughter ]
So he introduces me to his wife,
and then I'm like,
"Hey, by the way, I'm first up,
I'm a little nervous.
If you're in the room,
like, please,
like, 'Wakanda forever'
with me," and he was like,
"Uh-huh...
Cool, okay."
Little awkward, but I was like
"Great, nice, nice to meet you."
We go down -- Me and my friend
go down in the escalator,
and she's like, "Oh, my God."
I'm like, "What?"
She was like, I cannot believe
that I just met Ryan Coogler,
the director
of 'Black Panther.'"
I was like, "Where was he?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Where was he?!"
She was like,
"What are you talking about?"
That's who you just
asked to 'Wakanda forever.'"
[ Gasps ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was like, "Oh, my God!
I am such an idiot!"
And so we tried
to go back up to find him,
and he had, like,
disappeared into Wakanda.
He was gone.
I was, like, "Clearly, I'm not
gonna be in 'Wakanda 2.'"
But, yeah, so anyway, I asked
the director of "Black Panther"
to 'Wakanda forever.'
[ Laughter ]
-It would've been great
if he had said to you,
"And if I'm having trouble,
if you could just
go 'Black-ish.'"
-Yeah.
He didn't say that.
He was just, like --
[ Laughs nervously ]
[ Applause ]
Foot in mouth!
So embarrassing!